I think commercial advertising to me
which is incredibly competitive but it
was my film school because I teach about
everything did she about lensing I was
able to operate so I operated on 2700
commercials so by the time I'm ready to
UM film I completely did operate on the
duelists and on alien I wasn't allowed
to operate when I came in to LA on Blade
Runner but I was very selective about
who I choose because I need come with a
great team so I chose Jordan chromeless
right and so I was it but I was able to
talk with an operator about operating
and I said I want to get in closer of
the lens I think it's too wide and and
I've always had that that is a there's
an evolution from stills so the
viewfinder is just a viewfinder so all
my time doing stills that I was really I
still have the camera shoes so no German
camera called an exactor verax and it's
got a top prison or you can do that and
change the filling but it's your eye to
the viewfinder so you're actually
composing and it's exactly the same as
composing and I don't give a damn
whether it's a narrow flex or a
Panavision or whatever it is